let's do another example where we have
some data we want to fit a line to that
data and maybe use that to estimate some
of the some of the data that we didn't
collect so to speak
so the first thing they asked us well
let's look at the chart first of all
this is birth year they started in 1930
they go all the way up to the year 2000
and in increments of 10 years and they
tell us the life expectancy in years so
a good thing for us I think this is the
United States and the life expectancy
has been steadily increasing and the
first thing they asked us to do is to
make a scatter plot of the data and I
did this on excel ahead of time and this
is what I got as you can see in 1930 was
59.7 in 1930 it was 59.7 in 1940 it was
62 point 9 these blue dots are just
plotting each of these each of these
data points in 1930 is 57.9 it's that
data point right there 1940 it was 62
point 9 it's that data point right there
so I just went ahead and plotted all of
them and then I let Excel figure out a
line of best fit and Excel I didn't go
into the math of how to do this we'll do
that in future videos that's out of the
scope of an introductory algebra but the
Excel figured out that the line of best
fit the line that goes that is least far
away from all of these points that
minimizes the distance from all of these
points is y is equal to 0.23 9 5 X minus
400 0.99 and I'm not going to go into
what r-squared is just yet but it's a
measure of how good this line is
actually fitting so let's use that let's
use this table let's use our line of
best fit to answer the rest of their
questions so the second question is use
the line of best fit to estimate the
life expectancy of a person born in 1955
so we have two options we could just
eyeball it 1955 is right there so if you
go up from 1955 you're gonna hit the
line of best fit let me do it in a
different color because that's the same
colors the dots in 1955 you're going to
hit the line of best fit right there
and if I were to just eyeball it it
looks like it's right there this is one
two three four five so these are
increments of two so it looks like about
77 years so 1955 it looks roughly equal
to 77 no no no sorry 67 years it'd be
clear that look sounded suspicious a 67
year life expectancy now we can use the
equation of this line of best fit to
come up with the exact value when X is
equal to 1955 what is y what is the life
expectancy in years let's get our
calculator out for this actually let me
use let me use a graphing calculator for
this one right now so let me clear this
let me clear everything and then let's
just a punch in 1955 for X so we have
point two three nine five times 1955
that's our x value minus four hundred
point nine nine is equal to sixty seven
point two three so our line of best fit
gives us the exact answer of sixty seven
point two three years so our eyeballing
it wasn't that far off so that's what
our line of best fit would predict if we
assume that a linear model is a good
model to describe this data and all we
know right now are linear models so
that's what we will use and it actually
looks pretty good it looks seems like it
fits the data pretty pretty good let's
do the next part use linear
interpolation to estimate the life
expectancy of a person were in 1955 now
linear interpolation means let's take
the data points around 1955
so you have this data point from 1950
you have this data point from 1960 let's
draw a line between those two data
points and assume that the 1955 number
would be right in between on the line
there now we could figure out the
equation of that line we have two points
we have the 1950 data and we have the
1960 data we could figure out the slope
of the line we could
that's why intercept then we could
substitute 1955 in there but this is a
line and 1955 is right in between these
two points it's five from either one so
on this point right here that's on that
linear interpolation on that orange will
just be halfway between these two so we
can even average those so let's do that
so if we just average those sixty eight
point two plus sixty nine point seven is
equal and then we want to divide it that
answer means our previous answer so that
number divided by two is equal to sixty
eight point nine five so part two part
two in through linear interpolation we
get sixty eight point nine five is that
what I got sixty eight point nine five
so that is this point right here so
linear interpolation is giving us this
is linear interpolation on this right
linear int that's giving us a slightly
higher estimate than our line of best
fit across all of the data and you can
even eyeball it if you look at it right
there let's do the best one the next one
use the line of best fit to estimate the
life expectancy of a person born in 1976
once again we can use the equation of
the line of best fit plug in 1976 here
and see what it gets us I mean we can
eyeball it 1975 is there 1976 is there
it'll be right around there let's
actually use the actual equation so in
1976 this is going to be the line of
best fit the line of best fit is going
to give us if we actually figure out
what this line value gives us so we get
0.23 nine five times
1976 1976 - four hundred
point nine nine so seventy two point two
six years so it gives its seventy two
point two six years so equals seventy
two point two six let me make this clear
here these columns this one right here
is line of best fit and this right here
is interpolation
interpolation now they want us to use
linear interpolation to estimate the
life expectancy of a person born in 1976
so what they want us to do is draw a
line between these two points and then
use that line not the whole line of best
fit to figure out what 1976 might have
been now
before 1955 was right in between those
two values 1976 is not right in between
those values so let's actually figure
out the equation of this line using
using the points using these two points
using the points 1970 comma 70.8 and
1980 comma seventy three point seven
let's figure out the slope of that line
of this line right here so the slope is
the change in Y over change in X it's
going to be seventy three point seven
minus 70 point eight seventy three point
seven minus 70 point eight that's how
much we changed in the Y Direction
divided by how much we change in the X
Direction 1982 - 1970 1980 - 1970 so
this is going to be equal to let's see
three point seven - point eight is two
point nine so it's two point nine over
ten or it's equal to point two nine we
changed to point nine years and life
expectancy every ten years over that
time period right there or 0.29 per year
now what's the equation of that line
well we know that the point nineteen
seventy and seventy point eight is on
that line
so we know that when x is equal to so if
we say the equation is y is equal to MX
plus B we know that Y is equal to let's
say it was seventy point eight y is
equal to 70 point eight when we know M
is point two nine when x is equal to or
when the year is equal to nineteen
seventy times nineteen seventy plus the
now we can calculate our y-intercept so
what is our y-intercept get our
calculator out if we have to subtract
this from both sides so B is equal to 70
point eight minus zero point two nine
times nineteen seventy get our
calculator out no there we go
all right 70 point eight minus 0.2 nine
times nineteen seventy is equal to minus
five hundred point five so this is equal
to negative five hundred point five so
the equation of our interpolation line
remember we're just finding the equation
of this line between 1970-1980 is that
equation is y is equal to 0.2 9 X 0.2
nine X minus five hundred point five now
if we want to figure out what that line
if we want to interpolate 1976 we just
have to put 1976 in there for X so what
is life expectancy in 1976 get our
calculator out again 0.2 nine times 1976
- five hundred point five is equal to
seventy two point five four so we get
seventy two point five four is what
happens is the number we get when we do
linear interpolation between those two
data points all we did is we figured out
the equation of the line between those
two points and then we plugged in the
number 1976 to get seventy two point
five four and that's a slightly slightly
higher number than what the line of best
fit gave us but it's pretty pretty close
in either scenario now let's do this
last part use the line of best fit to
estimate the life expectancy of a more
person born in 2012 and this is what's
cool about the line of best fit
we don't have 2012 year 2012 goes off
the table but we could just we could
just keep continuing on with this line
right here
I'm using the wrong color keep
continuing with this line right here and
see what what is this line equal when
the year is equal to 2012 so all we have
to do is put 2012 in for X and we'll get
with the line of best fit tells us get
the calculator out again so we have
point two three nine five times twenty
twelve minus four hundred point nine
nine is equal to eighty point eight
eight eighty point eight eight so this
last part in twenty twelve if you were
to use the line of best fit the average
life expectancy in the US will be eighty
point eight eight years anyway hopefully
you found that to be interesting
sometimes dealing with the data can be a
little bit hairy these aren't nice clean
numbers but it gives you a little sense
of why slope and y-intercept
interpolation and fitting a line is
actually very important to analyzing
data and coming to conclusions from that
data